[Music]
we're here with a new member of our team
on Sebastian I did pretty poorly on the
taxes friend see the first time do you
think you look better well usually I'm
not so good at tactics online but so I
don't really think that I will beat you
but ok I'll try my best
you're pretty good at tactics over the
board yeah over the board with note
online yeah we'll see okay we're going
takes the bishop beautifully it's going
for the forest oh yeah the first one
looks like missing one now they're
making one just so you know this guy is
really good at magic once nice now I
found it got ourselves an 18-3 here
let's see which I don't really see ah
now it is this whoops which should be
something like a blindness I think but
with colors reversed yeah it's going
quite nicely and then mate this should
be made
[Music]
hold on
should I just take it's even pin though
this really may I'll take this one
definitely very confusing only just
let's take this route don't really have
an idea behind my moves so many pieces
hanging yeah what should I want to take
this one and then take this one am I
missing something
let's go for this one well done so
what's my rating though it's getting
close out Wow
ah I just supposed to take tricky ah
this woman this guy what
really I could should take on edge 700
or just take them taking g6 and down the
net 7x okay working yeah
taking back
let's see ya mate him here
I have no idea let's that was wrong
again I didn't see that helps a bit this
one okay there's a root hanging let's
take this one that was what it was
better to take the Queen I didn't I
didn't know if this the Queen hang you
okay this is a standard one this one is
no where's tomato one good moving this
over mmm
feeling the pressure now hmm
so apparently we're done ah you didn't
make it either but it was a good try you
were much closer than I was think in
this case f5 just I fine I didn't see
that at all let's see if it's a fun
ten check here I guess we need the Queen
it's not bad okay just take energy for
okay okay
should I take this one as well okay
that's not so good just to make their
rating a little more pretty thank you
okay one more
[Music]